[Música]
yo soy un cirujano venezolano y recuerdo
siempre que las amigas de mi mamá
quería que yo fuera cirujano plástico
y evidentemente era por sus intereses
personales estaban vigilando lo que
podía suceder pero yo decidí ser urólogo
y siempre cuando digo urólogo me ven
como raro y piensan que estoy hablando
de neurólogo y realmente no es neurólogo
soy urólogo
y realmente lo que me ocupa es otra área
los biólogos no solamente vemos el área
genital logró logos también nos ocupamos
de los riñones infecciones urinarias
cálculos vemos otras cosas pero
básicamente asocian el urólogo con el
área genital como que somos los
ginecólogos del hombre
es importante porque cuando además
llegamos una fiesta y decimos que somos
urólogos empiezan a hacer las preguntas
y básicamente hay dos cosas que suceden
cuando llegas a la fiesta
lo primero que empiezan a preguntarte yo
tengo un amigo de un amigo que tiene un
problema y 13
al final te das cuenta que el amigo casi
te piden que le dé un recital al amigo
que tiene un problema y realmente lo
segundo que pasa es que empiezan a
aparecer los chistes urológicos todo el
mundo audios chistes de urólogos o te
empiezan a mandar chistes de urólogos lo
que siempre recuerdo es uno que después
que termina de hacer el examen físico
medio doctor usted me va a mandar flores
mañana
otro te dice doctor usted me va a llamar
mañana u otro después que tienes un rato
haciendo el tacto te dice autor encontró
la próstata
entonces realmente la razón es porque
nos asocian al urólogo con la próstata y
con razón porque el cáncer de próstata
el cáncer más frecuente en el hombre
inclusive en eeuu el cáncer más
frecuente en latinoamérica el cáncer más
frecuente no es la primera causa de
muerte por cáncer en eeuu
aquí en la primera causa el cáncer más
frecuente es cáncer el producto sin
embargo en latinoamérica si es la
primera causa es el más frecuente y es
la primera causa de muerte en el hombre
es cáncer de próstata cáncer de próstata
tiene gente que lo defienda igual que el
cáncer de testículo tiene su propio lazo
y tiene celebridad de gente que hablan a
favor y defienden el cáncer de testículo
lo mismo no pasa con el cáncer de pene
mucho de ustedes ni siquiera sabían que
el pene puede tener cáncer porque
definitivamente vamos a hablar de
alguien que lamentablemente no tiene
quién lo defienda
la buena noticia es que el cáncer de
pene
a diferencia del cáncer de próstata y
cáncer de testículo se puede prevenir y
eso es bien importante y es una
diferencia sustancial porque hay medidas
que podemos hacer para prevenir y evitar
y es lo que vamos a hablar hoy cómo
evitar el cáncer de pene
evidentemente
el pene es un órgano complejo
donde no solo conduce la orina por la
uretra o conduce el semen durante la
eyaculación tiene por supuesto que ver
con la mecánica del pene para la
penetración y tiene que ver por supuesto
con la identidad sexual entonces no es
fácil pensar simplemente que el problema
lo vamos a resolver quitando un pen y
poniendo otro porque esa no es una
opción
tenemos que eficientemente ver qué vamos
a hacer para poder evitar que le del
cáncer al pene
cuando la gente piensa en cáncer de pene
evidentemente piensan que va a haber
algún grado de resección del pene y es
verdad puede empezar con un tratamiento
local donde aplicamos o quemamos o
congelamos una lesión pero de acuerdo a
la extensión de la lesión tenemos que
hacer secciones del pene y podemos tener
que hacer una pennec tommy a total e
incluso el escroto y sacar los ganglios
linfáticos de la región inguinal
entonces es importante porque el
tratamiento puede llevar a
procedimientos mucho más radicales
cuántos hombres podrían vivir una vida
plena sin pene es una pregunta que hay
que hacernos cuando hablamos con un
paciente le decimos que tenemos que
cortar el pene tenemos que poner en su
posición y entender lo que significa el
reto de poder pensarlo solamente poder
vivir sin un pene
en el cáncer de pene
es probablemente no las entidades donde
es crítica la relación médico-paciente
es muy importante el vínculo que creas
con el paciente para que el paciente
entienda y pueda digerir la información
y te tomes el tiempo para explicarle lo
que tiene si el paciente no queda
convencido de lo que tiene y de lo que
hay que hacer el paciente se va a ir
y va a regresar cuando de verdad tiene
razón y va a regresar con enfermedad
metastásica entonces es muy importante
la relación médico-paciente es muy
importante el respeto a la intimidad del
paciente porque estás viendo la zona más
vulnerable la zona más íntima de un ser
humano y además la está viendo afectada
con una deformación producto un tumor
cuál incidencia se estiman 26.000 casos
en el mundo y en estado no van a haber
más de 2.400 casos este año a pesar que
en eeuu es uno por 100.000 habitantes en
brasil es error de 6 a 7 por 100.000
habitantes
en algunas zonas de brasil el cáncer de
pene es más frecuente que el cáncer de
próstata para que tenga una idea de la
dimensión si el cáncer de próstata aquí
es importante imagínense que en algunas
zonas de brasil el cáncer de pene sea
más frecuente que el cáncer de próstata
o sea definitivamente es un problema que
afecta y es un problema global
una de las cosas que más me ha impactado
cuando vea estas cifras es que en eeuu
el 72% los afectados son hispanos y por
eso es la importancia de que podamos
transmitir este este mensaje porque nos
está afectando a nosotros pero no sólo
nos afecta a los hispanos a los latinos
sino que aproximadamente una media de 11
años donde nos afecta a edades más
tempranas no es que hacemos el
diagnóstico 11 años más temprano sino
que la población afectada es 11 años más
joven que la población no hispana
esto es un hecho sorprendente cuando
vemos que la sobrevida por cáncer
producto a la investigación y el
desarrollo y de la inversión en recursos
económicos para hacer investigación la
mayoría de los cánceres hoy en día la
sobrevida ha mejorado y cada vez menos
pacientes mueren por muchos de estos
cánceres a diferencia en el cáncer de
pene ustedes ven como la sobrevida en
vez de mejorar ha empeorado todos los
cánceres las curvas de sobrevida a los 5
años van mejorando el cáncer de pene va
empeorando es decir que a pesar de la
ciencia que no se invierte en estudiar
cáncer de pene
hoy en día mueren a los 5 años casi el
40 50 por ciento de los pacientes están
muertos que han tenido cáncer de pene
porque los pacientes van tarde a la
atención médica por supuesto se depende
de cada país fundamentalmente en estas
unidades vimos que no venían tarde
porque no tenían acceso al sistema de
salud o porque estaban ocupados
trabajando realmente no van porque
tienen vergüenza de reconocer y
aparecerse con un tumor en el pene
porque tienen miedo de lo que pueda
suceder o porque no no entienden la
dimensión del problema y que esto puede
definitivamente afectar su vida
cuáles son los síntomas básicamente
puede aparecer cualquier lesión sobre
todo en la punta del pene cualquier
lesión cualquier masa cualquier verruga
que no desaparezca después de un
tratamiento hay que tener cuidado porque
esas lesiones muchas veces hay que
biopsiar las
cuáles son los factores de riesgo la
infección del virus de papiloma humano y
los hábitos higiénicos
en la falta de circuncisión neonatal y
el cigarrillo cuando hablamos del
papiloma humano es muy importante que
estemos claro y la idea no es crear
alarma que si usted tiene un virus de
papiloma humano va a tener cáncer de
pene el virus papiloma humano es un
factor de riesgo como hay varios
factores de riesgo lo que sí sabemos es
que hay una clara relación entre el
virus y el cáncer porque en los
pacientes con virus papiloma humano es
seis veces más común el cáncer de pene y
en los tumores de pene encontramos el
virus hasta en un 85% de los pacientes
entonces hay una relación clara entre el
virbac y lo humano y el cáncer no
significa que el hecho de tener virus
obviamente va a tener cáncer pero si
evidentemente al tener un factor de
riesgo
tienes claramente que ir a un proceso de
cuidarte y de supervisar y consultar al
médico más frecuentemente
la vacuna para el virus papiloma humano
no solo es útil en el cáncer de cuello
uterino y es un mensaje importante la
gente piensa que es para la solamente
para las mujeres porque piensan en
cuello uterino la vacuna también debe
ser usada en los varones
cuando se habla de conducta sexual todos
pensamos que el condón es suficiente es
verdad el condón protege una parte
importante del pene pero no la protege
todas por lo cuales es importante además
de usar el condón por supuesto conocer a
su pareja
cuando hablamos de los hábitos
higiénicos es muy importante porque
nosotros tenemos la responsabilidad como
padres desde pequeños a los niños
enseñar a retraer la piel del prepucio a
hacer los hábitos higiénicos porque
ustedes ven el esperma que se acumula y
el paciente que no logra reducir la piel
no logra ver lo que hay debajo del pene
y por lo tanto no logra ver ninguna
lesión que está creciendo entonces es
muy importante enseñarlo de chiquito a
que la piel tiene que retraerse para
poder examinar la punta del pene
y hacer un hábito higiénico adecuado
es muy importante cuando vamos de
higiene porque la gente dice bueno si al
final el problema es la piel y el
problema es bajar la piel para hacer la
limpieza porque no hacer la circuncisión
es muy importante que los estudios han
demostrado que la circuncisión podría
evitar el cáncer de pene solamente
cuando se hace en infantes o en recién
nacidos no tiene el mismo efecto
beneficioso cuando se hace en
adolescentes o en adultos ya por qué
porque ya los cambios inflamatorios se
dieron en el pene entonces no tiene
sentido hacer la circuncisión ya de
adulto
eso no previene el cáncer de pene lo
único que realmente previene el cáncer
de pene es empezar desde temprana edad
los hábitos higiénicos
en conclusión y ese estudio danés lo
demuestra que ellos lograron reducir la
incidencia del cáncer de pene solamente
mejorando la educación y los hábitos
higiénicos es importante y la
circuncisión debe solamente ser
recomendada cuando hay en aquella región
donde las condiciones higiénicas mínimas
no se puedan garantizar por supuesto el
cigarrillo al igual que otros cánceres
en el cáncer de pene también es más
común entre fumadores los tratamientos
ya vimos que pueden incluir la recepción
parcial o la resección completa que
implican una disección ganglionar además
de la cirugía del pene hemos mejorado
tremendamente en esta cirugía hemos
reducido la morbilidad de la cirugía
pero no es suficiente tenemos realmente
un compromiso ya hablamos de que el
cáncer de pene el trasplante del pene no
es definitivamente una opción tenemos
que buscar cómo resolverlo
este es una foto de un grupo de unos
médicos de brasil donde básicamente el
doctor tobias machado donde se ve
claramente como el pene ha sido
destruido completamente por el tumor e
incluso el paciente infectado
comprometido se le hace una cirugía
paliativa de rescate retirando el pene y
el escroto y a pesar de estas cirugías
de rescate este paciente de 21 años a
los 7 meses muere entonces
definitivamente tenemos un compromiso
tenemos que ver cómo hacer para crear
conciencia para seguir hablando y que la
gente esté consciente que el cáncer de
pene es una realidad y tenemos un
compromiso por supuesto como hombre como
médico y como papá tenemos que educar a
nuestros hijos tenemos que hablar de las
relaciones sexuales tenemos que hablar
de la enfermedad de transmisión sexual
tenemos que hablar sobre esta realidad
porque no debe seguir muriendo ningún
hombre por cáncer de pene y bebés no
debe seguir ningún hombre caminando que
haya sido amputado por un problema de
cáncer de pene simplemente porque no
tenemos el compromiso de educarlos para
prevenir el cáncer de pene gracias por
la invitación
[Aplausos]